[Music]
in subtitled porn news submitted by
pickle ring oh I get it
go Rick pornhub is introducing closed
captioning to allow its hearing impaired
viewers the full experience we're so far
yeah I can't watch porn with audio I
don't need the audio yeah you don't need
the audio it's such a turn-off when I
hear how fakin it but now I'm so happy
they're subtitles can you can see the
[ __ ] but don't you want to hear that
never watch porn ever again whenever I
hear that noise other pictures that
[ __ ] face I should do it now it's
done I should do those sound effects
porn Foley yeah yeah you know like they
do all that [ __ ] okay
[Music]
yeah it's not like a bird flying off
[Laughter]
clothes rise the picture what do you
guys hear it also sounds like a penguin
legit sounds like somebody fingering the
[ __ ] out of somebody yeah you're just a
[ __ ] pervert that's all no ketchup a
penguin shaking himself out - no closed
captioning might be really hard on just
like getting an octopus out of an ice
chest ignoring this because besides
besides the dialogue and setting up the
sex scenes and stuff like that in the
middle of it oh ah
that's all Oh h h KH h harder the
descriptive sometimes
oh yeah like like lightly chattering boy
lines yeah that's true like macking up
the lips a mouth and gorged with cough
you guys can't me me Julie found away
gargling they're gonna do that what's it
called
cough cough that [ __ ] AI porn thing
where they put your like superimposed of
cases on shape oh these are some
examples they never turn me into a porno
of choice they're actual lines and porn
what's you la she's trying to get into
the [ __ ] program or is it a really
it's probably a schoolgirl scene yeah
University of labia you didn't have
people over here while I was away they
even have punctuated correctly miles
away
did you Oh see when you read it it just
makes it 10 times worse it's like it's
that bad well you're technically an
automatic failed what unless you suck my
[ __ ] is a next line I am very cold
there just looks like a regular video of
a missing person next to the telephone
pole yeah I'm very cold
I'm so glad now that the hearing
impaired can now enjoy poet porn it's
full effect
because personally I skipped the stories
I just go straight to I fast forward 10
second 15 seconds straight to the
[ __ ] get a little bit of that
fast-forward see what the [ __ ]
penetration looks like fast forward fast
forward fast forward not next video
that's all that's my important next
video what's the next video for if you
netted no no I didn't know
browsing man that's like my youtube
viewing experience ever watched a porn
thing from beginning to end
oh hey just go to the part you like yeah
why are you so quiet do you have
anything to say I'm just listening I
think I've tried but you guys are I is
pretty boring if you watch the whole
but I also feel bad now because I know
these guys spent a lot of time on the
porn production memorizing the lines and
I know what it takes yeah but if
choreography if the acting was better
and the cinematography was better I'll
get the [ __ ] out of here it's just
people [ __ ] no no no no no no
yeah but the setup takes too long like a
drags and a dialogue and it's kind of
like sometimes it's not believable you
have like this 39 year-old girl like oh
I mean scuse me my nails why do you
think they do what do they do that for
you know that she's always crack me up I
must I'm in school teacher it's like
[ __ ] away trip you're [ __ ] fooling
nobody man good like it's like what's it
called like nineteen year old girls I
bet you are solid thirty-eight yeah by
nineteen my ass dude get the [ __ ] out of
here
she's got veins in her [ __ ] boobs and
[ __ ] [ __ ] a wrinkly ass face ruining
my fantasy doing a team boobs you know
we're all ladies get those boob jobs and
[ __ ] and their [ __ ] tease Albania as
[ __ ]
they got [ __ ] varicose vein holidays
got varicose and I've never seen
varicose veins on titties so that's
pretty gross I mean if you do have it
miss fine anyway so yeah this feature
this new closed captioning feature has
been added to one thousand of the site's
most popular videos within this straight
popular with women excited by and
transsexual category okay guys don't
give a [ __ ] what do we know everything
yeah yeah yeah Oh straight I didn't hear
the string in my bag yet so it's part of
porn hubs philanthropic wing called
pornhub cares they also have a I like
that Department they have a pornhub
descriptive video channel that launched
back in 2016 so it just expands that
have you ever watched porn and then you
look at this girl and then you get
disappointed and your boner goes away
there's like you could have done more
you're too pretty for this I've seen
somewhat there's one right I look at her
and I'm like you could have been an
actress and you could have done so much
more with your model a model or
something else and then my boner dies
and then I'm just then yeah I stop
thinking about yeah I look at her I'm
like look at that I'm like you could
have done so much more and I get
disappointed in her and you just thought
and you close your life to feel like I
can't do this anymore I will not support
oh no I don't cause I find somebody else
who's just a little uglier but still
pretty what's so weird the other way
where damn she's killing I could let you
she probably gets a lot more work than
all the other girl because I researched
now through JK news what we talked about
how much porn starts making out they
don't make as much they used to so she's
not making that much money for me I'm
like finally thank you someone normal
someone high do you say that the girl
next door girls the girls that look like
any other girls they they're like the
most popular porn stars - yeah I don't
like - girl next door though cuz I just
recently started watching porn again
just for a little bit didn't like the
girl next door thing some of them were
kind of busted yeah a girl next door was
busted yeah like the girl next door
real neighbors like literally it's your
neighbor [ __ ] on camera I don't like
it I don't like it like what the pain
I'm very selective about my pornography
I mean it's getting bad dude it's like
that shit's like now it's like [ __ ]
people looking like family members and
[ __ ] purse somebody's on somebody's
nephew
thumbnails I'm like it's just normal
people [ __ ] every age every legal age
I'm just looking at it like man I don't
[ __ ] do this to watch this that
what's this there was a walking this
Russian pornstar she looks so pretty and
like just visually perfect I was like
you could have been something so much
more and I got disappointed which
country it was like some kind of Russian
or no they could have done Navy over
there okay I forgot her knee I don't
know her name I don't know any of their
names but they you know could you match
by so fast to it but so that's like your
Napster down remember you see like all
those like Eastern European girls and
they look like they could be supermodel
yeah yeah not over there but these
average you gotta set some dick over
there want are a lot of actors I started
in porn industry though like Jackie Chan
yeah I think Jackie and it's funny you
could see it he's like in his early 20s
or something like that
he's [ __ ] bad day but Jackie Chan
Cameron Diaz
Deanna Stallone Sylvester Stallone did -
I know that yeah a porno dude if you
cook you gonna look like Cameron Diaz is
like it's not the actual porn but it's
like behind the scenes of it and you see
her titties and she's like in this like
blue leather thing or some [ __ ] like
that yeah I was very exciting for me all
these celebrities that got their start
in pornos yeah that's crazy all right
yeah I think I thought that Chris Pratt
did it to war I don't he was a stripper
I saw a local celebrity strippers yeah
he was also homeless in Hawaii or
something I know there's a lot of things
you gotta do but the other like damn I
don't know if Jackie you I think you
just want to do it for fun cuz he was in
the Chinese opera as a kid right oh yeah
yeah yeah yes I don't know though wasn't
he Chinese up but you still poor though
maybe could have been a passion project
the Chinese operas it's like you know
you like lived there yeah it's like one
of those was a college preparatory or
yeah yeah we got a live there and really
breathe the art yeah like Sammo hung was
there too I can't picture Jackie Chan in
a porno though even though I already saw
it Oh
because I'm big drinking [ __ ] rush
hour Jackie Chan you know rush hour
Jackie Chan was [ __ ] 40 years old
yeah and still moving like that he look
like he was like in his 20s that's slow
Jackie you see Hong Kong [ __ ] yeah god
damn
who's doing the [ __ ] handstand
push-ups of [ __ ] I bet you got a TD
thousand percent why why do you see that
why are we betting because his energy is
like I understand it I don't know the
remember watch that documentary and then
he was talking about that egg scene in
one of his movies and he goes if you
gotta shoot a hundred takes to get it
right you gotta shoot a hundred yeah Oh
CG record for like the same scene so
focus is intense yeah I think if we if
we shot twenty tapes of like moving on
bucket it could be focused ad D though
focus what does that mean yeah like like
you have a TD but because of martial
arts teach you how to hone it was gonna
channel a channel that [ __ ] and just go
all the way he swims like a [ __ ]
he's looking around you ever see him
he's like it's like you forget that
you've been doing it so then you just
keep going
that was like an interview where he was
talking about he hated he he doesn't
want to do films in America anymore
because it's about moving fast and kind
of using your money as quick as part
it's more of a business yeah exactly so
like he would he wasn't trying to lose
money all day well he's he's like the
superstar so he says like I want a
hundred tasted this I want a hundred
takes and is it like this clip of him
like kicking up a vase and doing a
roundhouse to it and he did what Brad
dude he can't get what he wants in
America so he's like [ __ ] that yeah not
a little [ __ ] spoiled [ __ ] yeah he's
like I'm the king in China so I could do
whatever I want but I wanna come to
America no I can't
[Music]